benvenuti sanità story questa volta
stiamo di notte gameplay e indovinate un
pò chi è tornata come faranno più
tornata che grazie mi avete scritto voi
nei commenti che uscito il nuovo gioco
di graham i gremi tre sono si sono un po
particolari ma questo lo vedremo subito
comunque oggi andremo a giocare al nuovo
gioco di crema e in più
andremo giocare a tre anni versione
natalizia cita gremio negre di due
versioni natale poi sempre lasciate un
bel mi piace se volete vedere altri
gameplay o meno simile tesi voi giochi
che volete che proviamo azzur nei
commenti
mettetevi comodi predilizione per
iniziare abbiamo una lettera se scritto
ciao considerando il tuo livello di
crimine il governo ha deciso
consultandosi col giudice avrai una
possibilità di ripagare tutto quello che
hai rubato durante i tuoi anni da ladro
e potrai evitare la prigione
siamo dei ladri quindi recenti questa
offerta la tua missione sarà di aiutarci
dovrai rubare nuovamente quindi
riprendere alcuni di oggetti di valore
ai fratelli gemelli bob e bach
loro si stanno nascondendo in una
vecchia prigione abbandonata e sono
molto pericolosi accetti questa missione
quindi noi eravamo dei ladri ma il
governo ci ha detto non ti facciamo
andare in prigione però ci deve aiutare
a riprendere degli oggetti da questi
gemelli molto cattivi e pericolosi va
bene accettiamo il colorno sento quindi
di gioco si chiama the twins
ed è appunto dai creatori di grendi e
dovrebbe essere oi figli gemelli di
gremio i fratelli gemelli di grammy la
sua missione riporta questi tre oggetti
di valore
scappa dalla casa attraverso la porta
d'uscita quindi dobbiamo trovare un
diamante la gioconda pochissimo ma
bisogna non fatto a rubare la e poi una
moneta ok
proviamo così bob e bach sentono tutto
quindi come grant
bisogna andare molto più di provare a
fare sia inizio ricorretti di fare piano
perché potresti farti male quando la tua
barra della vita è finita vuol dire che
hai perso
se stai giocando con una tastiera
assicurati che il joystick
vabbè ma noi stiamo giocando con nota
del cellulare
tutto questo proposti gemelli faranno
paura come gremite mezzo video raggiunge
i 20 mila mi piace faremo anche the
twins ei gemelli nella vita reale
privilegio di un bel mi piazzo questa
dovrebbe essere la pressione abbandonata
c'è scritto che ho bisogno del di porco
per aprire a coletto
fate bene attenti se vedete gli oggetti
fu brava anna dove sono caduta questa è
la prigione faccia un piano sono
arrivano a elite il salario o parsa un
po di vita che cerca in questi oggetti
che hai fatto l'amore che ho fatto è
stata una scarica elettrica tv 11
dirigenti che brutta aveva una torcia
sponsabile già chiuso dentro una gabbia
adesso non è più difficile di green in
cui ti risvegli facciamo uscire da
questa cambia adesso che cosa è quello
un campanello e facciamo scappare da
questa prigione adesso devono fare le
chiavi ok io ho preso le occhiaie
aspetta che se ne parlasse per sì siamo
usciti questa prigione e cos'è un posto
l'inter si fa per dire lo stesso
ok siamo riusciti a scappare da quella
prigione dobbiamo trovare quei tre
oggetti anche perché loro sono due hanno
alcuno quindi ancora più difficile un po
come in grande i due c'è qualcosa qui
vediamo disinfettante marmo che prendilo
magari ti può servire un passaggio
segreto che bravo è già pronto un
passaggio segreto una parte di un
revolver prima pistola qua c'è
qualcos'altro
sto magari può essere un nascondiglio
scrive pure che ha bloccato in tempo ma
si dai che non ci vede che li troveremo
questi oggetti
ma c'è qualcosa che ancora non abbiamo
trovato neanche un oggetto
[Musica]
così a questo rumore
questo cielo perché c'è questo rumore
per questa musica inquietante dire che
non c'è niente qui è tutto buio
lì ce l'ha ma non forse lo possiamo più
forza all'improvviso tra l'altro gemello
vittora diverso bene se siamo nuovamente
risvegliati allora problema motorizzati
10 apporto sia le chiavi che il pezzo di
pistola sono 100 domani che brutto chi
si somiglia gremi sono sicuramente
parenti ce lo stop resto qui lo avevo
visto chiave rossa si aprirà per questa
porta e una di loro ma ora vediamo qui
su cosa abbiamo
c'era qualcosa che si illuminava una
chiave blu anche accesso è una cosa che
si illumina guarda questo che cos'è all
le munizioni della pistola basta attento
c'è un laser non possiamo passare qui
possiamo provare a roma per i se ci
abbassiamo forse la dobbiamo disattivare
vediamo da questa parte che non
significa che non ci pensavo fossi treni
invece una statua
aiutarli se poteva aprire la porta si
muove la lotta ma si augura
il papa ci sono tutti e due
contemporaneamente 15 hanno chiuso da
un'altra parte adesso quindi è cambiato
come ice cream
vi ricordate quando vi prende quando si
prendeva poi si rinchiudeva dentro
quella torta di cantina ogni volta che
sentiamo a scappare in un modo diverso
di taleggio e riuscito a scappare di
michelucci anche l'altro qui andiamo
appena di sopra ma quando cambia la
musica non è che abbiamo seminato a asi
contare su che cosa acceso prova a
salire ma mi sta seguendo
nell'accordo aveva tutti qua grazie
piccoli ha preso quindi da quello che ho
capito non finisce il gioco con i giorni
ma con la barra della vita che vedete
sull'alto bravin di abbiamo diciamo metà
vita adesso
in più c'è il temporale non so se
riuscite a sentirlo voi c'è un temporale
fortissimo fuori con i lampi e tuoni
quindi ancora noi adoriamo le cose
paurose ormai lo sapete io qua avevo
visto un altro passaggio segreto eccolo
qui che c'è la sola ma che cos'è che
cos'è la fogna alle cantine allagate
oppure la fogna
avete qualcosa si ama guardare alla
prigione che non ha mai scappato noi ci
siamo svegliati dinamite bene questo non
possiamo utilizzarla a caso kaboom
decresce uno della fantasista non loro
ma brano l'entrata sarà gestito è
complicatissimo non capisco stiamo per
morire completamento e in più ho perso
pure la dinamite
esco prenderla cromo sui e vive da meno
piano piano così forse non mi faccio
male ai ha fatto cadere il quadro ora
faranno arrivato torri mondo
ma adesso gliela tv e dietro di te
dietro di me ma non è esplosa mi sono
salvato
no mi sono abbassato pure in cosa è
calata la nostra vita magazine abbiamo
bisogno dei nostri consigli magari fare
prima prova andare in con l'altro
passaggio segreto che c'è quella norma
deve saltare però appena devo saltare
ecco perché vogliamo cosa sia in questo
caso ok siamo felici qualcosa qui non lo
ha fatto
c'è insomma dove siamo è una specie di
ruota
è una specie di meccanismo ovviamente
passando rumore loro sono arrivate solo
metà siamo morti
vediamo che succede
ma ci vorranno fare arrosto
[Musica]
i mod
beh vi metterà gremi 3 molto difficile
secondo me ma passiamo ora l'edizione
natalizia di grevy due o è piaciuto il
nuovo gioco di grendi grandi 3 the twins
scriveteci nei commenti che voto gli
date da una 10 se volete che faccia un
secondo gameplay del gioco
andate a vedere il canale di vitale
perché anche il suo canale facciamo il
gameplay ma ora passiamo a granny
capitolo 2 in versione natalizia vedete
sia una decorazione li natalizia vediamo
cosa è cambiato 15.01 tigre mi dove si
sono sì a tre mesi a g g ma ci svegliamo
nella storica nata ad un pochettino
diverso questa volta è più brutto nel
sotterraneo ci hanno messo questo quante
porte ma l'identità dei turisti sulla
camera ecco perché ci vede sorvegliando
dalle camere sono state solo musica
stiamo anche perché qui non c'è niente
che povera volete cercare
promossi anche creme sente lo spirito
terrestre sarà più buona qua c'è
qualcosa che fa paura però c'è bisogno
di un'area la cassetta di sicurezza
manuale del coleottero però seguita
l'elicottero etto neanch'io
beh devo dire che ha buon gusto
saliamo le scale abbiamo visto brenta
non so se tale tipo che questa porta
chiusa speriamo non arrivi lei qui
adesso la televisione che cos'è questa
cosa a un pezzo del quadro mammamia quel
lavandino che bru c'è qualcuno chiuso lì
dove se qualcuno chiuso la ragazza ha
preso un polipo che cos'è si è andato
tipo in una pozzanghera c'era un colpo
forse abbiamo ancora il manuale
dell'elicottero della sera il figlio di
gray però da questa passano le camere in
sicurezza infatti noi siamo scappati
subito di qua siamo allora sopra qui non
si poteva andare vero no dobbiamo stare
di qua allora prima di qua di nuovo di
quello si può ma operiamo chelucci
stanno arrivando a noi andiamo da questa
parte visto che ti facciano come se
c'era sotto guasta ma scantinato c'è
questo caso bologna una pistola avete
sentito vuole monitorare
riprese di proiettili cos'è questo ho
paura della cosa che si fine la gabbia
guarda ma il caro babbo natale tipo la
cosa storpia io provo a spararlo da qui
per un anno al drago premio guardare
visto il polpo ha cercato di prendere
anche gremita aspettano sta adesso le
regate aiuto adesso pubblico scappare
questo tool pd era solo un colpo adesso
che faccio peggio per te che lei
sprecati e poi lo sapremo come
funzionava ma mi aspettava proprio lì
intanto questo non potrà mica scema che
puzza bloccati qui per un po adesso
dobbiamo aspettare che vada via
ok scarpe con i tacchi la pistola che
già citato prima
lei è andata là dentro nella coppia che
sto facendo di casa gabbia dove fare il
mostro a me sarà trappola li ha detto mi
sento albero di natale possiamo salire
su che cosa c'è c'è grande acqua la
cucina non c'era neanche accorto vi sono
le camere di sicurezza
max e non lo sono c'è chi no c'è
qualcosa in mano no cos'è questo sarà un
pezzo della foto
non gli ho fatto niente
3 secondo voi ce la faremo
secondo me non lo so tornati al piano di
sopra ciò è questo ma radio perché
creiamo giorno a quattro per ultimo
giorno allora proviamo a vedere che cosa
c'è qui se non lo fece nonno scappata
ma mi ricordo che bisognava prendere la
chiave del nonno ti ricordi abbiamo
giocato un sacco di tempo fa grandi due
quindi non mi ricordo più niente però mi
ricordo che bisognava prendere la chiave
e lei è lì è questo che cos'è io o no o
non solo di mostri trappolato adesso
cos'è questo non lo accetterò z non sono
stato io ai parto rumori elabora qualche
cosa c'era non mi ricordo
no qui quello dove c'era il polpo che
mostro
[Applauso]
non si può saltare ultimo giorno
[Musica]
no perché mi chiamo buste radicata non
si può
camminò anno qua era chiuso scappa
scappa
eccoli tutti e due vestiti da babbo
natale ci hanno chiuso nella formazione
della tortura
game over
lasciate un bel mi piace se volete
vedere altri gameplay
se volete vedere altri giochi
consigliati se li prende gli aumenti ora
vi lasciamo quattro casse linea su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite
buona visione
[Musica]